the bag's only going to teach you the
body mechanics
because the form is so idealized
okay it's it's not much better than a
solo form okay then you don't want to go
into a sparring situation
without having a whole bunch of other
skills that you actually don't need for
the back
okay just like you don't need them for a
solo form on one is timing one is
measurement one is weapon selection
okay so um we're gonna we're working the
front kick
and i have to have the proper timing
the proper range um my foot might help
me do
something so if i find like oh i'm going
too early i'll take a step
it's just a micro step and i find i'm
going too late
boom i come out and absorb that in i
might go
uh oh i went too early boom i'm going
us i chose thrust i'm a little late
boom i'll choose this now you see
so his job is to come in
same thing goes on the round so he's
coming in
my step will help me do what i need it
to do
this foot is measuring okay so he's
coming in
don't just have one thing that you do
over and over because it might not be
right
stay more in this situation but
maybe i can float down because he got a
little close
rather than he comes in and i'm jamming
my weapon
okay but okay so
i'm working on closing the gap uh
i don't want him to have a beat on me
okay so the first one we're gonna deal
with is his hand
his hand weapons so it's just like joe's
ski
one the joe is only an inch so you
you're moving you're going around an
inch when you defend
against the jolt ski so here is this
it's about two inches that that part i
i have to keep moving okay so he's
he's not doing anything i'm gonna lower
myself
i'm gonna compact myself and i'm really
thinking about keeping that thing moving
okay keeping it moving
so i have to have some spontaneity in it
okay i'm trying to fake him but
if if now he's gonna try to tag me as
i'm coming in
okay so maybe i'll try and fake him and
work
but maybe i'm thinking i could tell he
falls like you're gonna nail me
okay then maybe i have to do a conscious
angle of deviation okay so that's the
drill
you're going to have more success with
this drill if you're not hesitant
so stay there just feel it
psychologically
and then the other one i want him
thinking whoa he's coming i want
him to rush
okay so i'm i'm pretty aggressive
as i'm paying attention to what he's
doing
if i can beat him i beat him
okay let's go okay so i am
bridging this gap and pressure
pressing him so that he does not want to
throw the kick because
it's going to get jammed okay so if i'm
not
aggressing or i don't have any
consciousness of his
kicks then he'll just kick i'll never
get there
okay so when i close i
i have to close make him realize
don't throw the kick i even have to get
past the knees
okay then we're dealing with that chap
okay and i'm looking for the jab as i'm
moving in
um with my
pressure with my juking
but also i'm very much in the moment of
that jab so if i need to i'll slip
what have you now we're dealing with the
uh
right cross so the counter right he
looks boom i'm
i'm paying attention and this is where
all the other g skills come in okay
so strategically the drill bought me
past
the leg i could tell he's leaning
forward so he took out his knees
right i'm joking enough that i got past
the jab he decided to counter right
and so this is where i'm gonna i'll slip
the right boom
okay so i have to press
to get past the legs i can't come out
like this
okay so i'm pressing past the legs right
and looking for smothering the jam the
jab starting
and juking so he he's practicing his
timing
he's looking for that we won't throw it
open in the back
okay he's trying to we'll pop good
timing
he's working on his counter right boom
and i'm doing the same thing
[Music]
okay go so he's going
and i'm looking come on dude
i'm just looking for that camera right
you see so his angle deviation took
too much from his line of attack
i'll trade
go
i'm gonna win that trade
same thing so switch rolls
come over here so i'm going to be
compact
now here we go see the difference
and come back
so look at it get a better sense
and that's your game boom that turn your
hip
lower your center boom
turn your hip more boom drop your knee
look up stay in the fight
that's your goal you see
well pressure i'm pressing here i'm
pressed past your legs did you have
lumbar in the hook
boom drop your knee turn your foot drop
your knee flare it
out balance tight compact
here we go
boom come on drop your knee turn your
foot head up
guard raid your shoulder
drop your knee watch your balance flare
your knee out
compact okay let's go